bereits zum 5
für die schönen und zitrone abschmecken
[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in sallys welt
heute gilt braunen schmecken und zwar
mit einem leckeren hefeteig und ganz
ehrlich sehen sie nicht perfekt auf sind
sie nicht perfekt und ich finde gerade
jetzt noch zur sommerzeit kasten
stromschlägen einfach hervorragend denn
ist es schön erfrischend licht extrem
gut und trotzdem richtig flüssig und
soft und einfach noch gut also ich finds
im schnecken zu drohnen schnecken käfer
schnecken allgemein sind einfach sehr
sehr gut und ich zeige euch jetzt
erstmal die zutaten für den hefeteig
dafür verwende ich einen würfel hefe 80
gramm zucker 2 esslöffel warmes wasser
500 gramm da könnt ihr weizen oder
dinkelmehl verwenden 1 1 250 gramm milch
100 gramm weiche butter einen teelöffel
salz und einen halben teelöffel kardamom
der hefeteig ist wie jeder andere krieg
auch erstmal hefe zucker und wasser
verrühren da könnte jetzt frische hefe
nehmen oder auch getrocknete hilfe das
geht auch und entweder verrührt ihr
jetzt alles mit der hand und verknetet
dem teig mit der hand oder einfach mit
der küchenmaschine und ich mache jetzt
auch gleich so dass ich bei der can
durch die hitze funktion mit ein
schalter beim kneten dann geht der teig
nämlich noch schneller auf
[Musik]
dann gibt jetzt einfach das mehl und die
anderen zutaten dazu
butter und salz gebe ich immer zum
schluss dass damit die zwei zutaten
nicht direkt mit der hefe in verbindung
kommen es mag die hefe nämlich nicht so
gerne
und weil es ganz gut ohne pass kommt ein
bisschen kardamon dazu falls ihr sinn
ich habe lass das weg oder probiert es
einfach mal aus ich finde es sehr katar
zu und jetzt den hefeteig etwa zehn
minuten lang schön geschmeidig kneten
je nachdem welches million verwendet
kann sein dass er so ein paar esslöffel
mehl braucht je nachdem wie groß ebene
ist wie viel wasser ihr dazu gegeben
habt mir warte jetzt auch bis in das ist
immer noch ein bisschen weil ich mal ein
bisschen mehr ich glaube ich ein
bisschen zu großzügig mit wasser halt
ihr könnt ihr jetzt den teig
herausnehmen zu einer kugel formen und
dann zurück in die schüssel legen und
dann gerne aufgehen lassen für etwa eine
stunde bis er sich verdoppelt hat oder
mit hitze funktion dauerte nur eine
halbe stunde gerne auch bei der stoffe
im backofen getrocknet da auch nicht aus
und ich werde dann die zeit nutzen und
schon mal einen level zu bereiten denn
das würde die leckere füllung und
gucke ich immer manchmal nämlich back
transport zum formen wenn ich merke dass
der teig schon gut ist wenn ich merke
dass dabei aber nicht so ein bisschen
mehl braucht dann freue mich das ganze
eher mit mehl und kann dass mir noch ein
bisschen einarbeiten
[Musik]
und den teig dann auch gern ein bisschen
fetten und
abdecken
hohes level curt verwende ich zitronen
die sind um bargeld davon brauche ich
den abrieb und saft 150 gramm zucker
320 gramm stärke und später zum früheren
250 gramm quark und 50 gramm stärke
lasst euch von der griechisch geräusche
nicht irritieren sich draußen der
landwirt aufs feld der juni der rasen
mäht dem rat der kirchen ack eltern hört
sich nicht so an gleicher hat anderen
stars gleich hat gutes sie kommen aus
dem sound büro
naja was solls jetzt erstmal die zitrone
abreiben da immer darauf achten nicht
den weißen pater ansonsten wird es
nämlich bitter und dann den zitronensaft
auspressen und davon brauche ich dann
150 milliliter und ihr wisst bei mir in
der app und dem blog gebe ich immer
alles in gramm an denn klar ihr könnt
immer einen messbecher verwenden wenn
ihr ein gehabt aber wenn ich sowieso
zucker und andere sachen abwiegen muss
stelle ich meist einfach der topf oder
den messbecher einfach auf die waage und
gibt alles in gramm an dann muss man
nicht immer mit verschiedenen einheiten
machen deswegen steht bei mir in der app
alles in cham auch flüssigkeiten ja weil
es einfach viel genauer ist
[Musik]
foto wie geht dir gut schön dich mal
wieder zu sehen ja die zuschauer artig
vor vermisst das ist richtig aufgefallen
sondern da war ja
gestern in einer story wo man das mit
respekt dank gestiegener wieder da
jetzt verrät ihr hier die zutaten im
topf also quasi zitronenschale
zitronensaft zucker eier und die kleine
menge stärke und hier beim land lasse
ich jetzt die butterweck ihr wisst ja
bei meinem grundrezept habe ich auch
butter mit dabei bei lärm gehört einfach
trainer fruchtaufstrich ist aber hier
wird quasi die butter durch quark
ersetzt damit einfach eine schöne
füllung wird für die betroffenen
schnecke
[Musik]
jetzt schön türmchen frei früher
dann können das auf dem herd stellen
und den auf mittel hohe hitze stellen
und dann schön aufkochen lassen
[Musik]
jetzt am besten direkt umfüllen damit
das land schnell abkühlt einfach hier
rein und dann kann ich das später wenn
es etwas abgekühlt ist mit dem quark
unter stärke verheerender ist die
füllung fertig
bereits zum 5 für die schönen und
zitronen schnecken
die werten lecker
der talker darf dann corby und dem
talker mag
ich habe erschwere barbara schnecken du
[Gelächter]
kannst du dann abspielen dann habe ich
jetzt hier mein abgekühlte slevin gehört
da kommt der quark dazu und auch die
speisestärke die bindet hier einfach
noch mal den quark dass es eben auch
schon fest wird
[Musik]
juhu ich liebe tun
und dann könnt ihr jetzt hier den
hefeteig zu einem großen rechteck
ausrollen mit etwas mehl
[Musik]
dann kommt ihr die leckere füllung drauf
und wird schon verstrichen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
jetzt hier schön aufrollen
[Musik]
ich nehme meine große ofen form die
eckige und besprühte mit etwas faktoren
spray ihr könnt sie aber auch mit butter
bestreichen wenn ihr wollt
dann wird jetzt die rolle zugeschnitten
am besten nimmt ihr euch tatsächlich
einen faden denn wenn ihr jetzt mit
einem messer schneidet dann zerdrückt
ihr das ganze und wenn ihr jetzt quasi
von außen nach innen mit dem faden so
zuschnürt dann habt ihr eine schöne
runde schnecke und ich mach das jetzt so
dass ich hier
drei mal vier also zwölf zuschneiden ihr
guckt einfach je nach ofen blech größe
oder ofen form wie viel er machen wollte
eine runde form ist auch immer schöne im
iphone aber hier finde ich passte so
ganz gut mit der zitrone zu machen wir
das und ich fange dann immer mittig an
legt die rolle einfach mittig auf die
platte passt
und dann erst halbieren und dann nochmal
durch teilen
[Musik]
also erst viertel und jetzt jedes teil
nochmal drittel
[Musik]
es sind schüler
guckt euch mal diese schönen zitronen
schnecke sein also ihr könnt jetzt
entweder das ganze abdecken eine halbe
stunde auf gehen lassen bis sich das
volumen verdoppelt und dann im heißen
backofen backen oder ihr stellt das
ganze jetzt in den kalten backofen
schaltet dann den ofen auf 170 grad
hitze ein und dann haben nämlich die
schnecken einfach noch zeit aufzugeben
während der ofen aufheizt und wenn ihr
es jetzt richtig perfekt machen wollt
dass sie wirklich so voluminös saftig
und richtig delicious werden dann
schaltet ihr jetzt gerne noch die dampf
stufe bei auch im backofen ein denn dann
bekommt er holt richtig volumen
soweit ich das mal und während die dann
backen kann ich schon mal eine zitrone
oder zuckerguss herrschen
diese fingerabdrücke
im schlaf noch immer gebraucht
[Musik]
das kann man ja
[Applaus]
ich brauchen lassen ohne dass ich kann
mir taten
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
in ihr sind
schilling
[Musik]
so sehen die zitronen schnecken jetzt
aus ich find's einfach einfach
wunderschön und ich finde sie würden so
schon perfekt schmecken aber
mit einer zitrone puderzucker klausur
noch ein bisschen besser ihr könnt gerne
noch frischkäse dazu nehmen dann müsste
sie allerdings nach einem tag auf jeden
fall kühl lagern wobei unter uns gesagt
das hält jetzt zehn minuten und dann
sind die eher aufgefuttert also einen
tag habe ich nur die zehn schnecken oder
zitronen schnecken aufbewahrt das sind
aber auch meine ersten zu tauschen
deswegen gibt es heute der zitronen
potter zuckerglasur also nämlich 150
gramm puderzucker etwas zitronensaft und
vanille extrakt und ein paar zitronen
brauchen für die deko so heißt ihr
würdet ihr die klausur an
schön dickflüssig
[Musik]
mit bisschen vanille extract verfeinern
dann kann ich jetzt hier schon mal die
zitrone schneiden für die dekoration
und jetzt kommt die glasur auf das
gepäck drauf
[Musik]
die zitronen schnecken sind fertig ich
lasse ganz kurz abkühlen und dann hole
ich unseren häfen schnecken experten
bürger zum probieren
[Gelächter]
wo ist denn unser hefe schnecken experte
früchte gut
hier
etwa klar wird
also mich zu melden wie ist ihr hier
verstecken aufreißen auf weißen
aufschneiden um immer oder auch er als
geschenk immer ich habe immer
geschichten auseinander genommen aber
eigentlich ist so auch voll geil
ich probiere mal so
[Musik]
ist doch schön sommerlich
diesellok mit
[Musik]
anderen
wir sagen ja wir sagen einfach wir haben
keine wahl
ja die erlaubte gebraucht für die linken
aber ich weiß jetzt auch einmal ein
bisschen
wie luftig und cremig unsere leicht
zitronig geld
noch genau prüfen finger noch aus
er muss nicht weinen
ich habe schon beim letzten mal
war das also ein komplettes video machen
wie er hatte ich wünsche die cdu war
ziemlich zitronengelb auseinandernimmt
war okay also dieses rezept ist wirklich
sehr sehr gut probiert gerne aus und den
karton schmeckt man zwar im teig nicht
direkt raus aber ich bin trotzdem der
der optimiert den geschmack einfach im
hefeteig habe ich ein bisschen karton
drin das passt perfekt zur zitrone
würzen mich gelockt ja weil was da zu
dominant raus schmeckt aber es
verfeinert den teig einfach extrem gut
ja dann würde ich sagen wie perfektes
aussehen ja sind es irgendwie unseren
neuen lieblingsstrecken ja schon so
vielen sommer zumindest den song auf
jedem see fini tief also probiert gern
das konzept auf ich finde mit seinem
preis dazu ordnete zur richtigen
toppings habe ich übertrieben
entschuldigung zu trauen als tonding
unter noch so früh stärker zulegen okay
machen wir ja so verzerren wir jetzt
gleich unsere zu trollen schnecken ihr
könnt ihr auch ganz gerne vegan zu
bereiten wenn ihr einfach einen veganen
hefeteig zubereitet gibt es auch schon
in meiner app und könnte slammen körper
mit einfach nur mit stärke kochen
funktioniert auch alles prima also auch
vegan möglich deswegen viel spaß beim
nachbacken wer zum nächsten und schreibt
uns gerne welche hilfe schnecke euer
liebling ist zimtschnecken
drohnen schnecke ich hatte auch mal was
mit blaubeere
rosinen nuss schnecke noch mit einer
schnecke
lotus schnecke
ich hätte mir über schnecken
kokos schmeckt so gut mit
kokos schleck
[Musik]
wir haben
ok was wünscht ihr euch als nächstes
welche schnecke schreibt sie uns gerne
in die kommentare
[Musik]